all right we know this guy's here he's
been on before asians never miss an
opportunity to uh shine ladies and
gentlemen hans
kim will start tonight's show hans
kim a local legend he's been on the show
before here he comes
look at this guy
[Music]
here he is ladies and gentlemen one more
time for your first comedian hans kim
good to be here uh my name is hans and i
know what i look like but
i'm not that into anime uh
which is unfortunate because only women
who are sexually attracted to me they're
pretty into anime it's like their whole
thing i forgot i have resting anime face
i'm on days like oh very interesting
i'm not a racist but i did see an arabic
dude reading a book in arabic on an
airplane
which kind of freaked me out but then i
saw him fold the corner of the page and
put the book away
i was like oh thank god he's got future
[Laughter]
plans
[Applause]
i i think trans people should be allowed
to use whatever bathroom they want to
use
but i don't think suicidal people should
because they make a mess
i'm they don't always clean up after
themselves these suicide americans
um all right thank you very much on skim
in and out big applause break
welcome back to the show hans kim thank
you so much for having me
you do this so good and to think that
you can do this so well with your eyes
closed it is absolutely incredible
a lot of people try to soak in the
energies around them and everything but
uh i feel like the bass player feels
like you're making fun of them
i love it look at those things hey there
they are they're hey i'm a white guy
everybody look at me in my white eyes
all right welcome to the show hans thank
you so much another great set
resting anime face i could see that you
ever watch anime porn
no i do not no what kind of porn do you
watch
um last time i said i was into tickling
which i really i'm really into tickling
and uh
i asked you this before huh i'm very
interested in what you're jerking off to
it seems
like right hand or left hand can we get
a little uh
no i'm kidding tickling is that an asian
one no it's
any race tickling is a city in china
that
uh he really loves i love this chick
named chick ling
[Laughter]
i love it so hans what kind of asian are
you again i'm south korean ah
south korean the best of the koreas
there you go there's some drums from red
band because he thinks that's south
korean
super racist red band i love it han so
what has changed since the last time
that uh you've been on the show what's
going on with yourself
um i started an open mic in a park at
zulker park i do it out of my van that i
live in oh you live in a van
yeah okay he lives in a pimp van not
just a van he
has a really nice fan you put solar
panels on your
your van today yeah recently uh yoni
help me out from best barbecue
oh okay there's a shout out there you go
he just got his payment for helping you
with solar panels he just used us as a
vessel to uh hey i plugged you up there
uh i love it so uh what else is going on
in this van you
you gotten lucky in it yet not in austin
no no where where did you get lucky in
the van uh
in new york city and uh in the desert in
uh
next to joshua tree i had intercourse
with a lady
you what with a lady i had intercourse
with her oh my goodness that sounds so
missionary
and slow and safe do you use a condom
i don't know how asians do you guys put
a little mask over your uh penis before
you put it in
it's okey-dokey uh
do you use protection when you have sex
with women i try not to
but wow lord knows that if there's a raw
dog around a south korean will eat it
you know what i mean
come on just getting warmed up here you
know what i'm saying we're just getting
a kickstarter
oh oh han's kim is rubbing his belly
right now for those of you listening
he's starving
at the sound of that endangered puppy
i love it hans what's the craziest thing
you've ever eaten
uh i guess i ate octopus and squid which
is pretty normal in south korea
wow they weren't alive though it was
just the tentacles were kind of
yes when i asked you the weirdest thing
you've ever ate i thought puss might be
part of it i didn't realize octo would
be before that
you have any tricks when you're uh when
you're with a woman is there any special
things that you do with uh with your
mouth or your uh
penis or anything like that you have any
a special hans kim trick
you could show us um so there's a lady
um i like to uh she's big she's big
i love it when i can actually get people
to answer this question very rare but
when it happens it's beautiful go ahead
hans
i mean in missionary i like to like
cradle their head and just like hold
them really close
and like just oh [ __ ] get them as
i love it what do you get what'd you
guys think of hans kim's uh performance
ron white
this is uh first time seeing hans right
what do you think of this guy uh you
know i thought he had a couple of really
strong jokes in 60 seconds
so i got to give him a nod on that yeah
thank you so much yeah really nice yeah
absolutely
[Applause]
i mean i'm just coming on to these
shrooms so i really don't really pay
attention but
until he really gets kicking in so you
had to be the first guy so
i love it hans you have any other uh
special skills or talents you seem like
the guy that starts the races in all the
fast and furious movies
it's aiko tanaka um i i can jump over my
leg
oh we got it how many of you want to see
this can we get a drum roll for this
yeah absolutely here we go
hans kim's about to jump over his own
leg
incredible you didn't land it though
you want to try again and land it let's
do this [ __ ] hans kim
live on kill tony yeah
[Applause]
that's a kill tony first right there we
that's the first south korean to ever
jump over his own leg in the history of
the show it's been eight years running
new milestones every day uh hans we have
um you had a great set and we have brand
new
handmade leather kill tony joke books
uh that are completely empty and you get
to write whatever you want in this thing
made by
an incredible local artist named adrian
cavazos
he's on social media at bonsai with a z
in the middle bones
eye all one word and here you go it's a
brand new awesome kill tony uh book
there you go
that's hans kim everybody there he goes
the stylings of hans kim
how about one more time for hans
everybody there he goes yeah